hey what's up guys my name is ashana
welcome back to another episode of
churno fixes your code i'm in code
review this is the code review series
right this of course is a series in
which you guys send me your code and i
take a look at it i give my thoughts i
give some suggestions to people learning
programming and all that and hopefully
it's just a good time for everyone
involved last time we took a look at a
raytracer i'll have a video linked up
there if you are interested and today
we're going to be diving into a little
bit of a blast from the past we're going
to be talking about a game that i
actually remember from windows vista
except someone's made made it for some
reason i don't know if you remember
inkball but it was a game that came
bundled with windows vista i made a
version in c plus plus with sdl2 i have
a fair bit of work and open source
experience but not very much in c plus
plus more c-sharp javascript typescript
python java experience this is actually
something that made me want to take a
look at this project because i know a
lot of you
are familiar with other languages you're
not just learning programming for the
first time i think that it's probably a
minority who have never done any
programming before and they're starting
off with like c plus plus or c i mean
i'm aware that that does get taught in
university like a lot i remember
learning c in my introduction to
programming class however these days if
you're self-taught i feel that if you're
into games you're very likely using
c-sharp with unity or trying to make
some kind of java c-sharp game kind of
stand-alone or if you're into like web
development and that stuff you're
probably using like javascript python
that kind of stuff in fact python is
very much useful outside of web dev i
know a lot of people who started
learning how to make games using pie
game and python so the point being that
there's all these different languages
out there and if you're more or less
familiar with them but you're coming to
c plus plus
there's a lot that you might may have to
learn in fact this is my personal
experience as well i started learning
programming with java and i used that
for several years before working at ea
using c plus plus there are a lot of
differences between those languages and
there's a lot to learn when you come
into c plus plus so i'm excited to take
a look at benjamin's code ultimately and
see if maybe i can give some good tips
to all of you guys who are also in the
same boat project is completely playable
includes five levels in a homemade
binary format that is decentralized
runtime that's cool it doesn't use a
game engine and it was more project for
learning than anything else okay cool i
wanted feedback on my seatbelts and
project architecture especially the way
i handled the civilization and manage
the lifetimes of sdl objects okay so
those are two things that we will take a
look at if i were to continue
development i'd probably uh better
highlight the separation between level
and playable level again we'll find out
what that is in the future as well as
set up a less finicky build process yeah
the build system is definitely something
that is difficult to kind of wrap your
head around if you're coming from
different languages because c plus plus
build system is well it doesn't really
have a build system and everything else
that it has is kind of all over the
place so we'll take a look at that as
well currently all dependencies are
statically linked that's good and it's
compiled uh with mingw on windows okay
we might try and use visual studio
because that's what i'm gonna do you may
be aware that mingw doesn't support a
city thread very well this introduces
some compilation headaches yeah you
should probably just use visual studio i
apologize if you're on windows right i
apologize for the difficulty in
compilation okay
and if you do decide to do a code review
i would not be offended if you don't run
the game i don't even think i have multi
through any multi-threaded code anyways
okay so no need to really have threads i
guess there is no need from a
performance perspective okay for
multi-threaded code i see okay the link
to the repository
inkball let's take a look for those of
you who don't remember this this is
this is inkball this is the game that we
are talking about that i remember and
when does this are in fact this logo
over here
brings back memories so taking a look at
the repository which i will have linked
in the description below uh let's read
the readme it's an inkball game that's
still in development it doesn't need a
game okay cool it looks very similar i'm
working i have working collisions and
you can draw an ink trail which
interacts which balls interact with
that's also cool to do level creation
maybe
building these are not full instructions
all the pencils are linked gcc 17
you can see dependencies independence
take a look at that and uh okay so cmake
okay so it's built using cmx so we
should have no problems hopefully
running this inside visual studio needs
sdl to sdl image and ttf mingw threads
on windows as well test it with 32 bits
of all libraries for sporting okay i
wouldn't recommend really working with
32-bit these days i mean
i would just just go with 64-bit for
everything pretty much we're in 2021 but
aside from that i'm excited to take a
look but first i want to mention that
this video is of course sponsored by
skillshare for those of you who still
don't know what skillshare is skillshare
is an amazing online learning community
where millions of creative and curious
people from all around the world can
come together to browse their incredibly
dense and beautiful library of classes
on pretty much any topic and learn new
skills ultimately there are two things
that i really love about skillshare
first of all
the the variety of classes they have i
mean literally anything you're
interested in photography videography
like illustration even stuff like
business management productivity
marketing they literally have videos on
absolutely everything but also it's not
just about quantity the quality of these
videos is also exceptionally high
they're really kind of short and
bite-sized they're easy to digest
they're easy to get through even if you
don't have much time left in your day
and it's kind of formatted in a way that
just keeps you learning it's really easy
to take a look at like a 30 minute video
and just put that on the back burner
because you just you can't seem to find
the time to sit down for that amount of
time but skillshare's format is mostly
extremely bite-sized meaning a lot of
the videos are like 5-10 minutes long
which of course makes it easy to just
find some time during a break sit down
and keep yourself constantly learning
which honestly has so many benefits for
your brain skillshare is offering the
first 1000 people who click the link in
the description below a one month free
trial of skillshare premium where you'll
be able to literally take a look at any
of their classes and see if you like
them or if there's something there for
you so definitely check them out go
ahead and learn a new skill and huge
thank you as always to skillshare for
sponsoring this video so as usual the
first thing that i'm going to do is
clone it i'm not going to bore you guys
with the details if you have no idea how
to obtain like repositories from github
and all of that stuff take a look at the
other code review videos because they go
through the setup process really well
and i'm probably gonna start skipping it
from now on because i think you guys get
the point quick little tip though if you
have accidentally closed the explorer
window like i did and you still have the
command prompt open you can just type in
start dot which will just open a new
explorer window in the current directory
which is very useful let's go ahead and
c make this c make error at c make lists
add a subdirectory a given source okay
so i actually i'm going to focus a
little bit on the build system stuff
just because this person mentioned that
they are coming from you know other
languages into c plus plus and this of
course is very relevant to c plus plus
and will hopefully help a lot of you
guys out so as subdirectory given source
so what's what's going on here is cmake
is trying to obviously add this
directory as another kind of cmake
project but
it clearly just does not exist or at
least there's well it's not an existing
directory in this case so this is a
little bit unfortunate because i mean we
know from the dependencies that mingw
threads specifically seems to be
an actual dependency not like the rest
of mingw i guess i am going a little bit
off the book here because i'm trying to
compile this with visual studio however
yeah it you know it should obviously
exist here and it does not so what can
we do about this so over here it looks
like we have this mingw sc threads kind
of repository which looks like it is a
sequence 11 threading class
implementation which are still currently
missing which is what benjamin was
referring to it's also a header only
library so this is something that we
would ideally want to use in our
repositories and i imagine that's
probably what the original author of
this kind of inkball benjamin this is
ultimately probably what he was using so
let's talk a little bit about how we can
actually set up this dependency in cpl
plus a little bit better instead of just
obviously providing people with a
project where they download it they run
it and suddenly this does not exist this
in fact is a perfect use for git sub
modules so what a sub module is inside
git is basically just another repository
an external git repository that you can
include as part of your project so
you're basically just creating a link to
another git repository within your
repository the code isn't actually
stored as part of your repository it's
external and of course you have some
extra levels of control there you can
pin a specific revision like you don't
have to be always on the master branch
on latest code whatever you can have a
different branch of the repository you
can have a specific commit that's all
perfectly normal so what i recommend you
do for this is just add this repository
as a sub module now of course you might
be using actual mingw if you've
installed that on your system maybe you
don't need to do anything like this
however this is a good example to kind
of show how to do this
so if we go back a directory i'm just
going to type in git submodule add now
we know here that because add
subdirectories is used it's actually
looking for a cmake kind of project
right this has a cmakelist file so
that's kind of important because that's
that means it's going to work so back
over here i'm going to do git submodule
add i've pasted in this url and then i'm
going to give it a folder or like a path
to basically check out this repository
into so we know that it's going to be
somewhere here i mean we're already in
inkball so just basically include mean
gw is where we want to check out this
repository let's hit enter aha the
following parts are ignored by one of
your git ignore files so it looks like
this person has deliberately not
committed this let's take a look at the
get ignore and sure enough we have the
include directory being ignored
okay so i think this is the case of this
person has checked out the repository
but doesn't want it to be committed as
part of their actual like inkball
repository but again this is a perfect
use for sub modules so what we're going
to do is just get rid of include from
here and like i mean well we'll keep lib
there i guess and then we'll try and do
this again it's going to clone all of
this we should now have that at this
path in fact if i just
go ahead and open that real quick you
can see we have this entire
mingw threads repository so let's try
and run cmake again we'll probably have
to like delete the
all the stuff here so let's go ahead and
use that wonderful start dot thing
and let's go ahead and uh just run cmake
again okay so no more errors and we in
fact have build files that are written
so yeah that is how sub modules work now
the actual sub module uh information
goes into this git get modules file so
if we go ahead and open that real quick
and i'll just drag this in you can see
that we actually have this include mingw
and it's set over here and if you had
like a particular branch all the
information will kind of go over here
and to obtain that if you're cloning the
repository once you've actually pushed
the fact that you even have a submodule
you'll need to do that kind of recursive
thing that's what i usually do when
cloning any repository just in case they
have sub modules you can just clone
recursively to make sure that you also
retrieve all of the sub modules okay
cool so now that we have those build
files let's actually go ahead and try
and compile this with visual studio okay
so it's actually automatically created
x64 as the target architecture let's
just go ahead and hit build and we have
a whole bunch of errors because i can't
find sdl so i'm assuming there's no sdl
in this repository either all right i'm
not going to bore you with this you
should also add sdl as like a sub module
or maybe even commit the built binaries
if you want for each platform that you
support i'm gonna go ahead and just
download the binaries for sdl and the
header files for sdl set all this stuff
up and we'll be back okay so i've gone
ahead and added sdl all of that seems to
be okay now however we have a bunch of
other errors let's take a quick look at
them as a learning example so first of
all use of designated initializes
requires at least six plus latest i'm
not sure if this is something that is
fine in uh
in like gcc g plus plus however to use
like dot x and all of that stuff um
inside visual studios compiler it seems
that we need to be using the latest uh c
plus plus version so like c plus plus 20
basically so if we go into like c plus
plus and um i never remember where this
even is
okay it seems to be in general see
what's language standard you can see
it's set to c plus 17 which he said that
it supports but clearly it does not so
we have to use c plus latest and this
should these errors should go away quick
little note as well
compilers differ greatly i mean maybe
not greatly in the grand scheme of
things but there are definitely
differences between compilers so make
sure that if you are kind of working on
a serious simple plus project especially
if you support more than one kind of
tool chain and you want it to be kind of
uh you know multi-platform i mean even
if you don't just as a sequel plus
developer it's obviously better to not
specifically use
um you know things that are specific to
a particular compiler and in fact i
think i saw one other thing here so
let's go ahead and try and compile this
one more time i mean one of the things
that separates like a junior sable plus
developer from a senior sequel plus
developer is the fact that the senior
developers are a little bit usually more
aware of the fact that you know there
are other compilers out there and the
differences between them because that
stuff is definitely something that you
don't typically come across if you're
just working
kind of in the beginning and you're not
really that experienced okay illegal
reference to non-static member here
um
oh okay so type of so type of um
yeah i think there were errors to do yes
the type off is not a valid template
argument type of which i mean i think
it's type of in like c sharp so maybe
that's where that's kind of leaking in
type of is a gcc like gps plus specific
keyword right so it's not actually
portable the portable versions as far as
i'm aware is decal type right so if you
use decal type i better not be
embarrassing myself so decal type and i
just looked this this up to be safe
decal type is uh standard across c plus
plus since c plus 11 and again what it
will do is literally look up the kind of
static compile time type of whatever num
blocks is right so if num blocks is a
un16t that's effectively what we're
doing here we're just figuring out the
numeric limits of un16t however of
course uh well that's 64. because i'm
used to writing that but you're in 16t
right so instead of writing this we can
kind of use a variable for that instead
or at least look up the type of the
variables that if we decide that this
changes we don't have to go back and
adjust all these numeric limits so in
general it's a good idea but just make
sure that you're of course using the
more kind of portable keyword and the
keyword that is c plus standard not just
specific to gcc okay and the final error
looks like cannot open mingw i don't
think we need that because mingw threads
is a header only library that we seem to
be using so i'm just going to go ahead
and go into the linker and probably just
get rid of this and hopefully that will
just work okay and we are good let's go
ahead and try and run this okay we need
all of the dlls so clearly they're not
statically linked to these libraries
okay so i've just pasted in literally
all of the dlls that come with all the
sdl libraries that we've used let's go
ahead and hit f5 and we finally have
this game oh wow that seems to be
lagging a bit
okay
when i move my mouse it doesn't do
anything oh
what's
this oh my goodness so game over really
is game over because look at that memory
leak
escape for menu
still happening select level one
okay stabilized
and then what happens when this goes in
here
memory leak time okay so that's one
thing i think we can definitely fix
uh
seems to be some kind of just massive
constant allocation of memory every
frame
in the menu screens which is a bit odd
but other than that let's ignore that
and see how long i can run this for
without crashing but yeah the other odd
thing that i've noticed is
that every time i move the mouse the
whole game freezes so that's a bit weird
oh cool like okay so i can draw like
that let's try and actually get this in
it makes it kind of annoying to play
i mean i don't know if that's a feature
because like it doesn't seem to be like
maxing out a core or something
right
wait what am i supposed to do with this
why is it not
let's try level four oh
now this is like practically unplayable
like this
surely it's not meant to be like this i
don't remember what the vista version
was like
um but other than that yeah like pretty
cool game i guess
um
i'm interested in how the drawing is
made i mean i'm assuming it's just a
bunch of lines
but anyway that gives us a few things to
take a look at and also in my notes i
have the um benjamin wanted feedback on
several husband project architecture so
we kind of talked a little bit about the
seatbelts build system and then also the
way i handle decentralization and manage
the lifetimes of sdl objects i feel like
managing lifetimes does need to chat
considering that memory leak but also
destabilization is something that we'll
look at okay but the stuff that
interests me right now is the memory
leak because that's kind of an issue
obviously and also the weird kind of
freezing
when we like move the mouse and again i
don't know if that's a feature i mean
it's possible it is but to me it seems
like some kind of weird bug because i
think it makes it really annoying to
play uh so we'll definitely take a look
at that okay sterilized level scene i
don't know why we have this open oh
because we fixed all the decal types
okay well let's take a look at the
general kind of structure and we'll work
out ourselves into fixing that memory
leak so
okay we have the main it sets up a game
on the stack and then hits game.play
pretty
pretty uh you know normal architecture
this seems to be a very common um
architecture which is fine i have
nothing against this you know it's also
worth kind of pointing out whether or
not you actually need this and if you
can maybe just have like a you know
game play or like start game function
and you don't need to like make an
object out of it but again the reason
why it's i think it's okay is because
you know a lot of people coming from
c-sharp java are obviously very much
into object-oriented programming and i
don't know i don't think there's a huge
deal with that in this sense uh you know
overall i think object-oriented
programming maybe we should make a
separate video on this but i think it's
okay i just think that you can't rely on
it too much and you should just be aware
of the fact that not everything has to
be op but you know i don't think op is
specifically bad especially for a lot of
cases like this okay anyway so we create
a window i'm not gonna you know dwell
too much on this kind of sdl code
uh load level from path okay so i guess
we can take a look at the
decentralization so decentralized level
information um first thing i'm going to
do is actually take a look at what the
uh at what the levels look like so
they're they're in binary right so let's
go ahead and just see if we can open
this my favorite binary editor by the
way is hxd i think i've mentioned this
before
um but let's go ahead and drag this in
just so we can take a look at the format
okay how big is this file
uh looks like it's 1.18 kilobytes all
right and then we have yeah ink level it
looks like the header and then a bunch
of
random stuff here which i imagine is
probably the positions of things so
let's take a look at how we are actually
processing that load level from paths
decentralized level information we have
a bunch of vectors blocks pockets balls
i'm assuming we just read like a size
argument so this takes in a buffer
immediately so does that mean that we so
level digitalization read
takes a path from this
why does it take this in
that's interesting
takes the game in because it needs the
game well apparently it needs to pass
the game into deserialize that's
probably the target of the data maybe
but anyway we have a max size which
seems to be like 10
[Music]
what's this 10 kilobytes this max size
isn't actually used anywhere so i guess
that's relevant okay we use a c api
which is fine you know i would probably
do read binary though rb
um i'm not sure i don't remember the
differences between all of these to be
honest i guess r is also fine because
it's not like it's text specifically
maybe it's binary by default um we get
the file size cool we make a new local
buffer of that size and then we put into
here so again you know reinterpret cast
changing char pointer to unsigned char
pointer that's not really necessary for
anything i mean to be honest there's no
reason why you couldn't have just set it
up like this by default but the other
thing is what i would recommend is
instead of using unsigned char um
just use un8t right so u int 8
underscore t it's the exact same type as
an unsigned char in fact if we take a
look at this it's going to actually be
an unsigned char right but it's a little
bit more portable right across platforms
across compilers and also obviously it
has the the actual
number eight inside the type so you know
how big it is
and i think that's important right so i
would change it to this and but again
you know it's
when you're dealing with pointers and
memory the type that it is is kind of
not really that important uh it's just
it's you know it's important for like
pointer arithmetic and stuff like that
if you end up doing um you know
advancing the pointer forward or doing
any kind of calculation with the actual
point of value uh however in this case
you know it doesn't really matter and i
would do this you don't need that
reinterpreted cast okay so a few things
that future churno notice me while
editing this video is there's actually a
number of problems here in this function
first of all we're opening this file
here but we're never closing it so f
open gets called we have this fp which
is local variable we read all the data
but we never close it so as soon as
we've read the data into the local
buffer which happens here we should we
can and should close the file by just
calling f close that's very important
otherwise the file remains open until
basically our program terminates because
this pointer then gets lost
the other problem is this local buffer
right this local buffer gets allocated
over here using new and then passed into
this deserialize function this
deserialize function then reads from
this buffer pointer but it doesn't
delete it ever so this is another memory
leak right we need to make sure that we
either delete it over here however i
probably wouldn't do that just to keep
it simple instead what we could do if we
go back here is once we have
deserialized this we could in fact just
delete this right you could just do
delete local buffer and make sure that
you're actually cleaning up your memory
otherwise this is just a memory leak
where every time you deserialize the
file not only
does the file remain open but you also
just never free this memory until your
program terminates i see you love
throwing exceptions which not not
something that i'm personally into but
it's okay you do you
uh okay deserialized let's take a look
at this so again you know and then we
reinterpret this into this you know
there's a lot of stuff going on here
like why take in a raw buffer you might
as well take something in that is in
this particular format
again you know pointers pointers are
pointers pointers are integers that
contain memory addresses the data at
that pointer is completely irrelevant to
the pointer itself they're two different
blocks of memory uh literally right
again again with the exception it's okay
so we try and figure out whether bytes
is less than the size of level have a
level header in which case obviously
it's not even there
i feel like these code review series
like videos they're just getting deeper
and deeper i mean i could literally sit
here for hours taking a look at this i
don't know if anyone will be interested
in that so i might just kind of speed up
a little bit but i don't know i'm always
kind of after feedback as far as what
this series is so definitely let me know
in the comments uh if you think this is
fine or if i should speed up
okay bytes needed yes we figure out how
much how many bytes we need to read i
guess and then we yeah so we have the
the gist of this is we have a buffer of
memory which we've kind of cast into
this header right so that we can
actually interpret it like that might be
worth making a little video about binary
civilization in general but we basically
go through this buffer now we have the
head of the actual data so we've
advanced the header amount and now we're
looking at the
like the actual information
of what comes next in the file structure
so in this case we seem to have block
information right and block information
just contains an x and a y right using
alignment here which is nice as well but
x and y and they're floats right again
that means that we basically have a
number of blocks that is defined in the
header and then all we're doing here is
we're iterating through and apparently
making doubles out of them but this
takes in doubles as well so
i thought these are floats
interesting
oh well yeah i guess you're just casting
them implicitly to doubles
sure storing those flows again i don't
know why their doubles here this sort of
slows anyway maybe you're using doubles
for some kind of extra precision and
collision detection or something i'm not
sure but i'd probably just use floats
for everything that's just that's just
how i roll okay so then we go through
the pockets i don't know what pockets
really are but same kind of situation
and then based on the pocket color
which is a
an enum value one two three or four we
basically set some kind of texture name
and i guess that's a texture that we
load
yeah this is all pretty standard um i
don't really have any problems with this
i like the fact that you use structs a
lot i think that when dealing with
serialization in binary it's important
to use structs like this right so
instead of having to deal with all of
these loosely you can just take that
buffer you know that it's supposed to be
like a header um and then you can
basically just uh you know cast the
buffer at a particular offset if needed
in this case it's from the beginning of
the buffer to be like a level header and
then that's it you've basically already
got all your struct with all of the
accessible information so the fact that
you're actually using structs here um
you know extensively for everything is
great i think that's a perfect way of
doing it the only other thing that i
would do because like when it comes down
to it binary civilization is obviously
very error prone yeah i mean like
there's other stuff we could talk about
like big endian little endian i don't
think that's a huge concern you know if
you're mostly working in like an x 86 64
kind of uh platform you'll be a little
indian and you don't really have to
worry about anything
however the one thing i would probably
do here is just make extensive use of
assets right so just literally every
step of the way assert everything make
sure everything is correct you're
throwing exceptions kind of instead
which is okay but
i just prefer asserts personally and it
means that you can kind of take away all
of this stuff and clean it up a little
bit when you're actually building like
in release and stuff again not that
exceptions that don't get thrown are
particularly expensive but it's just a
little bit cleaner in my opinion and
it helps you kind of assert a lot of
conditions which you're doing anyway but
otherwise it looks pretty good i mean
you're feeling vectors with values
returning them which may not be the best
idea but
i think that overall uh this is totally
fine and
uh yeah looks pretty good to me okay so
let's get real is it just me or do you
really want to find out what this memory
leak is because that's the thing that's
been bugging me so let's talk about how
we can track down memory leaks so
there's a few things you can do um i
mean the simplest way probably
is possibly i don't really do it this
way that often but you can actually take
a look at
um you know memory usage so you can find
memory lakes with this um using the
performance kind of profiling tools
inside visual studio let's have a go at
doing that because i don't think i've
done this very often oh yeah we'll get
rid of this because i had two of them
let's go back and
yeah this is fantastic let's go back to
our performance profile our memory usage
and hit start
there's a few other ways obviously and i
could um kind of show them but i'm just
interested to see so we need to do like
a game over
right
i remember this actually i have
definitely used this before um quite a
bit so we can take a snapshot like i
think before or after or something
um and yeah there's the memory so let's
take another memory snapshot and what's
going to do is just show like where the
memory is being allocated basically so
let's kind of um stop collection here
it's nice to do it before and after
because you can kind of see i guess
where like the memory has has gone to
but i think that it should be probably
good enough to just take one snapshot
when the memory leaks happening or at
least and at least it should show you
know what has allocated a large amount
of memory because clearly whatever has
allocated it it's used more than the
entire rest of the program like by an
order of magnitude probably so it should
be pretty easy so you can see that
during this we had 9000 allocations here
we have uh 58 000 allocations clearly a
lot more let's take a look at that so
we're basically just i don't know if we
can look at a like a hot path here but
let's go through this so you can see
that most of the allocations by far are
coming from the play function and this
is basically your call stack right so
it's coming from drawing which we kind
of expect get string size interesting
and then sdl ttf get string size ah
so what we are probably doing if i had
to guess
is
can i go to this function easily
is uh we're probably loading the font
file
repeatedly or something i don't know
what else would be causing a memory leak
um let's go okay so what is this get
string size let's just go to get string
size and let's take a look at this
okay so here we are opening the font
inside this function
and i guess never releasing it from
memory oh it's happening here as well
okay but here we close it
okay right so here we close it here we
don't so i'm assuming if we did this it
would in fact fix the memory leak um
obviously we don't want to be i'm just
testing this to see if it fixes the
memory leak or not how do i get a game
over or something
man this mouse thing is so frustrating
is this this i please someone tell me if
this is intentional i might send him an
email i'll be crashed
we crashed
oh sorry we use it here wow
journal review more like channel
breaking people's code it was working
before me yeah plea i need to probably
send an email and figure out i just
can't deal with this if this is
intentional this is nuts okay the orange
ball is heading in
okay yeah that looks stable so if we
take a look at this
um obviously we're not allocating memory
now let's have a quick chat about this
though do not open font font files
repeatedly here right now i can see why
you might be doing that right i mean if
we take a look at this we're not just
opening a static font file right over
and over again and then closing it right
we are doing it at a particular size now
the thing with these fonts is that again
unless we're doing something moderately
fancy like sign distance fields for our
font rendering we actually need to
rasterize our font at a particular size
right so
it's possible that multiple sizes are
being passed into here however this
again is something that you definitely
should i mean you know if you have more
time maybe for this it might be and if
you're actually investing into this game
and you're going to be developing it for
a while or setting up an engine which i
know this isn't but ultimately you
probably want like a resource or an
asset manager that would be able to take
care of this but what you could do here
at the very least is just cache this
actual font right because again opening
and closing it like apart from you know
well in this case causing a memory leak
it's just going to be very bad for
performance right there's no need for us
to actually do that so what we could do
is cache it instead now again the
problem is that we have a size here
right so it's not as straightforward as
just like you know let's just not you
know if we were opening it at a constant
size then that's easy we could do
something extremely simple such as just
make it like a static up here right and
then if you make it a static up here
i'm just failing today if you make it a
static up here you can set it to null
pointer and then just do basically like
a lazy load which is us being like
basically the first time it's used by
whatever it's used by we don't care we
don't need to explicitly initialize it
we can just basically wait for it to be
used and then the first time it's used
we set it to something like this right
and then of course we don't need to
close it and if we wanted to we could
close it as like part of our shutdown
i don't know if it's even necessary to
do this to be honest if you're just
terminating the application your
operating system will obviously reclaim
all the memory but to be nice i guess
you would want an initialization and a
shutdown or something like that
but anyway point being that uh you could
just do that but that doesn't work for
size because in this case this has
nothing to do with size meaning that
obviously it's possible that you might
want
um that you might want something a
little bit different in the sense that
like you might want like some kind of uh
unordered um it doesn't matter unordered
ordered map i'll just use a map to be a
little bit cleaner but you could have
your your size and then your actual
pointer right and then all this is your
little like font map and then that way
you can check to see if
if the key which is size exists within
that map if it doesn't exist you load
the font and you cache it in this map
right
um and then you just use it but if it
does exist then you just retrieve the
pointer from the map and obviously
everything is fine right so you could do
something like that and then you could
loop over this map and close all of them
if you needed to but that's that's kind
of how you could make it work with all
of this and again if you had an asset
manager that would kind of handle all
that behind the scenes all you have to
do is ask the asset manager for this
font for a given size and then that's
kind of it's up to the implementation
details of the asset manager to figure
out how it how it kind of functions
right and again if you're running out of
memory and this isn't used it could
start cleaning out assets anyway lots of
obviously very complicated systems we
could set up for this but uh you know at
a very at the very least i would do that
but to fix the memory leak and to keep
this code as simple as it is now
i guess we would
even though it hurts me
i guess we would just um
keep loading it every frame every time
we write this we write text but at least
close it you know um so that's kind of
yeah looking through the rest of this
code i don't see any other major
problems so we're drawing a bunch of
lines here
you know you're passing vectors by value
which you definitely shouldn't be so
just keep in mind that vectors obviously
if vectors get copied then they will
actually
do a heap allocation to contain all the
memory so it's not really about memory
per se it's more about performance
because dealing with large amount of
memory or allocating memory and then
freeing it and stuff like that that's
obviously going to take up cpu cycles so
we can kind of avoid that by just simply
referencing this instead especially if
it's kind of well in this case obviously
it's just read only just reading the
data from there you just need access to
the vector you don't need to actually
create a whole new copy of the vector
which is what your code is currently
doing so just remember
basically anything that is sizable try
and pass it by const reference now this
doesn't apply for things like vector 2
even though it is two doubles which is
16 bytes like that's not really that big
of a deal 16 bytes to copy no worries
the problem isn't really the memory that
we're copying it's the fact that copying
a vector like the vector copy
constructor you know needs to create a
new vector and creating a new vector
means we have to do a heap allocation to
contain all of the elements within the
vector so it's more or less the code
within the copy constructor and that
whole kind of you know creating a vector
situation it's the code there that's
doing the allocation that's the bad
thing not the fact that the vector
itself takes up space right kind of like
a vector2 would 16 bytes but it's okay
um same with like string again you know
for
stuff like text
the thing with this is that you know if
we're reading this text like what you're
doing here is copying the string which
again is not really ideal because if you
take a look at this right i mean let's
take let's use this as a little case
study
um and i think we i mean i really want
to fix that other bug but yeah these
videos man these videos are just so long
anyway uh what am i even looking for um
let's actually okay va find references
uh okay so write text so for example you
know we're writing text over here
you know what is this
um okay we have like press escape for
menu and then
yeah we've got like a bunch of
is this actual
oh subtext is what we're writing yeah so
subtext is i don't know what this is to
be honest but anyway subtext we write
like for example press escape for menu
right this gets written immediately
meaning that like you know in this
function in the scope of this function
this is all single threaded right you
don't need to worry about actually
copying the string in the sense that the
string's lifetime is tied to this
function right which means that we have
to be done with it or copy it by the
time this function is terminated because
this memory will in fact be freed right
so you have to kind of keep that
lifetime in your mind
so that being said we come over here and
we go to rendertex solid now what does
this do well this takes in a const chart
pointer and it obviously uses it
immediately internally right it doesn't
reference it and do something it will
actually draw it right i don't know
exactly how sdl works but my point is
that it will take that text probably
copy it into some buffer if it needs to
and deal with it meaning that in
basically here you can free the string
memory right as soon as you've given it
into here and this is how most kind of
renderers work right it has taken it
it's done what it needs with it it's
copied if required
and then that means that again it's not
your responsibility to keep this text
alive
uh you know
for like what until the next frame or
something no right you can be done with
it immediately so what that means is
that we don't need to make a copy of it
or anything like that right we can uh
just kind of use this existing memory
that
i keep losing everything um we can just
use this existing memory that we created
here right for this press escape for
menu why have this duplicated in memory
we don't need that we can just have it
in memory once which is here and in fact
this is probably going to be like a cons
char anyway but we can have it in memory
in a particular place and then that's it
so what you should do instead and of
course like in this case it is a conch
char but if you're you know maybe using
like um i don't know string stream or
something to like you know add in like
for example you were displaying the
score so obviously that's kind of a
dynamically generated string it's not
just in read-only memory and then in
that case obviously uh you know you
would be kind of copying it but again if
you know the lifetime instead of doing
that it'd be much better to use um to
either pass it by const reference or to
use like string view right using simple
plus 17. so you can just use string view
which basically just means give me a
pointer to like the string um and to its
end i guess uh and then that's kind of
it right so again you're not copying the
string you're just using the string that
you've already created over here right
because then then you get into this
habit of like okay but if i create
functions i have to pass stuff into
those functions
which means that it's almost like the
more functions you make
the slower your program becomes because
every time you call a function you're
copying everything into that function
that already exists in the parent kind
of calling function and that of course
is not something that we want to or need
to do right so just keep keeping keeping
keep an eye on that
and again coming from something like
java or c sharp it's kind of easy to
just not realize this because if you
have a string or you have um
this vector right which would be like a
list in java or c sharp like objects in
those languages are
like pointers essentially right they're
not actual
kind of stack allocated objects that you
can
copy if you were to write this exact
code in c sharp and it might be
something like public void draw lines
and then here maybe you have like some
kind of list
you know how would you write this in c
sharp well it would basically look like
this right so by doing this though again
list is
basically being passed as like a pointer
or a reference
not like this if you were to kind of
compare it to the c plus plus equivalent
and that's another thing that people
coming from java c don't realize in c
plus that like you know you don't have
to use the new keyword everywhere and um
you know classes like that don't really
translate it's kind of like a struct i
guess in c sharps structs and c sharp
are also kind of value based not
reference based but anyway the point
being that to convert this properly you
know you would actually have to add it
and add in that pointer but instead of
doing that in c plus plus we can just
add a reference um and again i guess
point of reference same same kind of
idea
but the point is this now means that
it's it will effectively work like it
would in c sharp or java
right if you were to pass in a list into
a function in the sense that it doesn't
copy the list it just references it and
that's how you achieve that in c plus so
that's another really important thing to
to get your head around if you're new to
c plus plus
okay so the final thing that i want to
take a look at is
this weird mouse lag thing right and
again there's so much we could take a
look at here honestly i could probably
sit here all day and just
go through this line by line
um but in the interest of time let's see
what's causing that because it's very
weird now i'm going to look at the game
loop because strangely enough again i
don't think it's actually a frame drop
because if it was a frame drop then we'd
probably see the cpu usage go up right
i think these frame times are fine so
let's go ahead and look at the actual
loop right because that's kind of the
first this is the entry point
essentially into every frame so we okay
so the first thing we do is we check for
events
um this is fine so if not should quit
i don't know if you should necessarily
handle this again i guess if there's a
quit event
then that will come up maybe but it
doesn't look like it would so i don't
know if we necessarily need to like
check that but we pull all of the events
we retrieve them then we go handle event
which what does that do okay that sees
what it all right okay so one of the
events could be a quit event which then
means you don't have to keep processing
events okay fair enough
um and then we yeah we can do all this
stuff mouse button again handle mouse
move i don't think this
uh i guess it depends what like playable
level i think is the actual level and
what was that handle mouse move or
something okay so if it's the left mouse
button then uh we draw like this trail
which uh yeah looks looks like it's just
a bunch of lines
um
okay sure
yeah don't really is drawing trails
surely that doesn't stop the balls from
moving
um it's drawing trail
that seems very local um okay sure
i guess it's a
no it's private
anyway um
so
yeah what could it be why is the
time changed inside the event
okay
so we get the
last equals now and then we get that and
then we calculate now minus last
but that's going to be like zero
so if we go through events and we update
the time to the current time
then we do this one little thing which
clearly takes no time at all
then we get now again so last is equal
to this
and then we get the difference this is
going to be like zero
this is probably why because we we're
effectively doing this
i mean if you wanna if you want it even
more clearer we're effectively just
doing this
right so the point is obviously with
delta time to try and figure it between
frames
so we want to see how much time has
passed through the entire frame
including like presenting the rendering
including waiting for vsync possibly so
i think this is the culprit actually
because if a delta time is zero nothing
will move
um okay you've got a max time step
that's good and you looks like you're
updating
more if you need to this is all pretty
good
sure um
yeah let's try removing this
that's my initial suspicion because this
is just evaluating to zero and obviously
if we keep getting events yeah there we
go that's fixed
if we keep getting events then we're not
going to move anywhere because we'll
always be
like literally you'll only get a proper
delta time if there are zero events
that's how it's currently set up
and yeah no memory leak
okay cool i haven't checked out all the
levels um i don't know if we
will
but
yeah overall pretty cool game um
i think that you know
for someone who's coming from other
languages you've done a pretty decent
job in using c plus plus obviously
there's a lot of things i would
personally change but it's hard to
differentiate between stuff that's
actually you know objectively good you
know i've tried to point out stuff like
that like not copying strings or vectors
making sure that you pass by reference
um
uh when needed because i like you do
sometimes with these pointers but that's
because the objects are like that
um
obviously being you know creating a
cache for your text stuff and possibly
an asset manager in the future
but overall like yeah this looks like
pretty decent code um you clearly seem
to more or less know what you're doing
again i'll just assume the memory leak
was like a bug
um and that just something that you
accidentally missed although you have
done it in two different functions no
actually sorry it wasn't a leak here but
again opening like i just have a problem
with opening this file like every frame
potentially reading it rasterizing it
you know well actually i don't know if
it gets gets rasterized here it might
get right it gets it might actually
rasterize each character as it needs it
when you actually try and render a
particular text string that's what i'm
assuming it does i don't think it just
immediately sets up like all of the
ascii characters or some kind of
character set into an atlas immediately
but who knows anyway the other thing
that i like is that for example your
level select menu actually uses um the
directory iterator from sql 17
to
find out which levels we have right so
it's all very dynamic if the file exists
there then you can load it basically
which is pretty cool i mean if we went
to our levels and we duplicated this and
we called it churno then i'm assuming we
would get a level called chono and there
it is we have a level called chono which
is the same as whatever level i copied
right so that's pretty cool a little bit
more dynamic i like that you also seem
to have all of these deleters
um
sdl window deleter
what's the point of all of this
um because you did mention you wanted me
to take a look at like stl lifetime
stuff
but what's the ah i see
okay yeah okay that's interesting so
you've put stl window and sdl renderer
into a unique point and specified a
custom deleter
right because obviously sdl is all like
c based and you have to explicitly
essentially have a destructor that calls
this
um i guess that's okay
like at the end of the day i probably
maybe i'm just a little old-school but i
probably wouldn't do this um and at the
very least you could probably you know
this these files are like a few lines of
code so you could just combine them into
one file called sdl deleters
and then just have them all there that
would be a little bit more organized and
we'll just reduce the amount of files
you have to browse through but i would
probably just have like an sdl init
function an sdl shutdown function like a
renderer in it render a shutdown or
whatever application in it application
shutdown manually call all of them that
for me that just
keeps it clean because like with a lot
of these things like you have to be
explicit with when they get deleted
right or shut down right so the order
matters and if you just have unique
pointers that are in a stack
that can be obviously a little bit
less explicit as to like the actual
order
anyway though i hope you guys enjoyed
this video let me know what your
thoughts were this was a very long one
and this was a hard one for me because
there was a lot of stuff to point out
and um you know i mean i didn't really
get into the game logic so much i more
or less talked about the code in the
code style and all the various problems
it had i hope that me solving some of
these issues like the memory leak and
showing how i approached that without
ever having seen this code before i hope
that kind of stuff is helpful to you if
you run into similar problems and also
maybe will prevent you kind of
prophylactically from writing that sort
of code let me know what you thought in
the comment section below if you enjoyed
the video please don't forget to hit the
like button let me know what kind of
content you want to see next in the code
review don't forget that you can email
me at channelreview gmail.com it will be
in the description below with your code
a little bit of an explanation as to um
you know whether you want to be
anonymous or not and what the project is
and hopefully i'll see you in the next
episode of the code review series don't
forget to check out skillshare using the
link in description below and i'll see
you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you